- Hey guys, it's Justine.
And today we're testing
out the new iPhone 12 Pro.
I'm gonna take some photos
and videos but first,
thank you to dbrand for
sponsoring this video
because I just put on
their new tempered glass
screen protector and this thing is...
It just blew my mind.
New iPhones mean new dbrand skins.
We also have one of their cases
but we also have something new,
we have their new tempered
glass screen protector.
And why this is very exciting
is because the new iPhone 12
is a completely flat display.
It will allow for some
very precise placement
of the screen protectors.
You might be saying Justine
'Yeah, but the new iPhone
12 has new Ceramic Shield
which is four times stronger
than the previous iPhone 11.'
Yes, it is but it is about the same
as far as scratch resistance,
so I do not wanna make the
same mistake I did last year
by not putting a screen protector on mine.
So we're starting off
this iPhone 12 right.
I mean they even give you a
little screen bubble pusher.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
- Wow!
This is perfect.
(knife scratching)
- Oh my God, it's not
even scratching it at all.
I just thought okay I'll stab it
and if it does scratch it,
cool, great,
I have another one.
I'll put that one on.
I'm so impressed. Let's
get a case on this thing.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, hear that!
That looks good.
Oh, did you need to dbrand your MagSafe?
You could do that too.
That's great.
Okay, back or not, oh it's a little windy.
Back on Life on Tyler's here.
Hi Tyler.
And like I've said before,
the biggest difference
between the 12 and the 12 Pro
is the 12 does not have a telephoto lens
and you could only shoot in 30 fps
as opposed to the 60
frames Dolby Vision HDR.
So, let's go take some
photos and videos, yes?
I still got a sprained ankle
so we'll take this real slow.
It is so beautiful.
It just rained so it feels so fresh,
it's so fresh.
What is that? Is that a
person or is that a...
That is a person's
feet, are they flipping?
Yes, they're doing some sort of activity.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
- Should we take a
picture of these people?
One thing I wouldn't be able to do
if I was shooting this on the
12 is there's no telephoto,
but we'll be able to see them.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
- I'm using the OSMO Mobile 4
to stabilize my shot as I'm walking.
It already has really
incredible stabilization
but just having this added
gimbal to get these shots
makes it look so much cooler.
One thing that I am excited
to show you guys though
is the difference between HDR footage
on the 12 Pro and the 11,
because right now you're not
actually able to see the HDR
because I'm exporting this video on STR.
But when you are really
taking this into final cut,
you're able to see the color detail,
you're able to see how
much more color you...
It's windy again!
They just asked who I was talking to.
I'm talking to my friends on YouTube.
So because I'm posting this
on YouTube it is an STR clip
You're not gonna really be
able to see the difference
but when you do take this into final cut
and comparing the footage
between the 12 and the 11,
there is such a huge difference
because you have so
much more color detail,
you have the ability to bring
up and down the highlights
so much more than you could
in the non-HDR footage.
So a lot of you guys keep saying
'but it looks the same'
I promise you, as someone
who has edited this video
and other ones, it is not the same.
(upbeat music)
- The front-facing camera's also amazing
because they have added an update to this
so you'll be able to do
front-facing Night Mode
which is kinda cool.
I haven't really got to test it out
as much as I'd like.
I did a little bit but
sometimes when it's really dark,
I just use the flash to get a good selfie
but the fact that they've added Night Mode
on all of these lenses is pretty cool.
Speechless.
(waves rolling)
- It just takes a good
photo every single time
That's a nice photo.
That's wasn't a nice photo.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
- [Justine] Hey bird!
(upbeat music)
- Everything in Ultra Wide
just looks terrifying.
This looks like I'm at the
Grand Canyon right now.
I'm not.
Spoiler!
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
- Let's get that wide angle.
I found a rock, it's pretty.
(soft music)
- It's nighttime which
means it's Night Mode time.
Night Mode is available
on every single camera
on the iPhone 12,
and it's only on the wide
angle on the iPhone 11.
The sun just went down.
It's not really dark enough
to really show you guys
how incredible Night Mode...
You are going to shut up.
You're going to shut your mouth now.
(laughing)
Obviously Night Mode
hand held is pretty good
but the tripod Night Mode
is where this really shines.
Let's go find some darkness.
Not that I don't love the
industrial roof or anything.
(upbeat music)
- Oh God!
(upbeat music continues)
- I'm so scared.
I'm not gonna sleep tonight.
(upbeat music)
- It's creepy!
I'm never gonna be able
to sleep, ever again.
That's a lie,
but it is really spooky.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music continues)
- [Justine] I can't wait to see this.
Wow! Look at the difference.
You could actually see the clouds moving
because it was able to take a 30 sec shot
Wow!
Well, I think you guys get the point.
Ultra Wide Night Mode on
the iPhone 12 is incredible.
Alright, I'm hungry.
We're done with this video now.
(laughing)
(plane engine roaring)